researchers at penn state university  discovered a new cell type in human  lungs which they call as respiratory  airway secretory cell they have taken  sample from five healthy individual and  perform single cell rna sequencing  and then they describe a particular cell  type which can be identified based on a  unique marker which makes it different  from any other lung cell type  this particular cell can be correlated  with the cause of copd  when they compared normal lung sample  with copd sample they found in this  particular rash cell there are several  genes which are altered which which are  roughly in the category of oxidative  stress immune function and metabolic  process thus this particular paper gives  us key insight about the genetic changes  in a newly dis described lung cell  that's one minute see you in next video